[Music]
cross stitch for rappers are you joking
i'm an anomaly in this scene for sure
i'm emma mckee and i'm a cross stitch
artist
i create custom one-of-a-kind
cross-stitch jackets for chicago's
creative class
[Music]
stitch is a
antiquated form of stitching
traditionally done by your grandma
i fell backwards into it um i made a
present for my mom a couple of years ago
so i taught myself how to cross stitch
it came very naturally to me and so i
decided to do more
i felt compelled to do it but i didn't
know what to do it for and then the
obvious connection was well i'll do it
for the things that inspire me and the
things that i loved were art and poetry
and music
[Music]
chancellor wrapper is like the the
prince of chicago you know he's chicago
royalty chance is one of my favorite
rappers and so i
made this jacket it was a three jacket
it was chances three i was like okay
i'll put this on twitter we'll see what
this does like 30 seconds later chance
the rapper rapper's followed you chance
the rapper sent you a dm i mean he's
like yo how do i get this and i was like
any way you want chance
and he wore it on the cover of billboard
and that was kind of like how it started
[Music]
this
is for
an artist named mick jenkins it's a
heart
i've made something like 135 pieces in
the last four years
some of the people i've made stuff for
scizza major laser chance the rapper vic
mensah most deaf joey perp kendrick
lamar oh yeah lil yachty of course how
could i forget about lil yachty but the
majority of them are worn by people who
are not famous a lot of people i make
stuff for in chicago wear their stuff
every day live in the things cross
stitch is just a cross stitch it's just
a square you basically take an image and
you pixelate the hell out of it so you
map out a bunch of tiny squares it takes
a very good spatial recognition a lot of
patience and you cannot mess it up
my inspiration usually will come
complete finished everything from a
person it arrives in my head fully
formed and that's it i have no idea how
we get there i don't sit around and
think about it for somebody like the way
that i'm able to make something for
somebody is if it is there
i have to go out to the suburbs to buy
my thread it's all specialty
i spend an ungodly amount of money on
thread it would freak you out
i always say like the median amount of
time in a jacket is anywhere from like
50 to 60 hours when you're done then you
get to pull the graph out and then you
can see what it looks like when it's
finished
[Music]
people call what's happening in chicago
or renaissance we have art and we have
music and we have all these people
making positive changes all these people
making incredible incredible stuff
i have a team that oscillates anywhere
from like 7 to 14 people and they're all
artists they're all other chicago
artists
we do these big photo shoots with people
it's like really the only way that i
catalog anything is by having pictures
of it i like those a lot the giving away
part is the best part to see something
that you've made affect somebody in what
seems to be a meaningful way is a pretty
emotional thing
the goal with the crosses checkups was
never to sell them or to make money off
of them it's truly truly a passion
project i'm not gucci i'm just you know
i'm stitch god
[Music]
[Music]
my friend
she gets me cookies this is my second
mom in new york it's a happy ride yes it
is
[Music]
i make charm for beyonce i make 10 piece
for her and i make a special charm for
30 rocks
[Applause]
every night i like to watch asap rocky
music radio because i like to watch my
merchandise my name is eva sam my
husband say your name is asap eva
[Music]
at this point you may be wondering who
the is asap eva and where is the story
going hell you might even be asking
yourself what is this story all about
fair enough let's start at the beginning
eva and her family immigrated to new
york from macau in 1982.
getting into the jewelry business was a
no-brainer for eva she comes from a long
line of jewelers we opened popular
jewelry in 1988 october 3rd in new york
in the beginning it's difficult
and then one day the rap god smiled down
on her and sent in capitano wu-tang clan
he's the first rapper to come to our
store after that he sent all the people
and we start to have a lot of famous
people come
travis scott jayden smith joey badass
golem young paris wi-fi funeral macho
famous people come because we do
everything on time make a good job for
them very quick and have a big selection
we have 24 karat gold platinum diamond
ruby ammo we have silver we have
everything and have a good personality
i don't treat them like a customer i
treat them like my own kids today was a
good day
ok
[Music]
family and jewelry are synonymous to eva
in fact the day after her son was born
she went straight back to work i would
not quit the job
i'm here every single day
popular jewelry is more than the sum of
its glittery parts it's a family it's a
home
and eva is the my customer call me gold
mother i have a lot to nickname what
they give me
that's really sweet
so
i'm chance uh i'm playing a show in
tampa tomorrow night and i want all
those hard of hearing and deaf uh in the
tampa area to come out and see our
seth show me through donald so i was
interpreting for a dram
and chance was that day watching and
he's like what's that and i've never
seen an interpretation happen like that
before we just want to turn
and then you look at the death community
like yo we have like our own rapper he's
moving like a rapper but he's signing
too okay this is it too
[Music]
my name is matt maste i'm the ceo
creator founder of definitely dope being
a hip hop sign language interpreter
we're outside the norm and the usual
standard of sign language interpret
your mission is to really make sure that
this audience who never really
experiences listening to music can see
it in a way that they can relate to it
with their language but they can also
understand it in its own context without
it being blurred or lost in translation
if somebody say turn up at the club i
think of how he looks in the club people
are just
let go so i'm thinking that's how i
would define what's
it means to turn up because if my signs
turn up it doesn't look the same it
doesn't have the same effect compared to
if i say turn up
[Music]
[Music]
in my life i can't change
[Music]
i got my hearing aids when i was too so
i've always had hearing aids the whole
time growing up college when i was 18
that was my first time really starting
to learn something
hip-hop that was like my outlet to just
try to practice on my own just so that i
could keep up with regular conversations
and then i realized okay signing on is
easier too and then people would see me
find songs and be like yo that's cool
i love providing hip-hop and music to
another culture that never really had
the chance to experience it before
there's nothing i said to where we feel
included now why not create something to
where people can feel included and not
just be that
[Music]
hi i'm mike green i write music for tv
shows
coming up next much much more when
lifestyles returns prepare for the most
advanced hot wheels ever
[Music]
science rules the tv show you're
probably here for is the bill nye the
science guy theme
science rules
how did i get into this business i came
to los angeles to be a rock star i did
not become a rock star
i learned the recording business so i
started doing a lot of songwriting
producing
a lot of records david bowie cypress
hill kid frost ice cube
and i also started getting tv stuff i'm
gonna be a doctor just like you i wound
up doing tons of barbie commercials hot
wheels commercials
there's oprah dr oz lifestyles are rich
and famous lots of different shows
when i got hired to do the bill nye the
science guy theme song they said we
don't want it to sound like a kid's show
[Music]
the theme song that i did which is kind
of this hip-hop thing it may not sound
like it's groundbreaking today but at
that time it was pretty bold of them to
go with a song like that
the beat is an up tempo hip-hop beat
and a number of the things like the bill
bill bill bill it's basically if you
listen to jump around
jump jump jump jump
there was one day here at the studio
where we had a bunch of rappers i asked
them you know what go into there and
yell
bill
bill bill
i don't even remember who was there
could have been
alt be real with cypress hill might have
been there kid frost might have been
there ralph m from funk dubious might
have been there i can't really remember
that's how the song goes
for the bill nye the science guy i want
to bring in real singers because that
was me singing that i sent those and
they said why are the voices different
right here well because i wanted to put
in real singers i mean this the original
version that's just me that's a scratch
track no put your voice back on there
it's funnier
[Music]
i give bill a lot of credit he wanted
kids to learn about science and he
wanted them to love science not for the
splashy elements of it but just because
the actual knowledge of science is cool
i feel really lucky that i was involved
[Music]
thank you